alec castonguay christian dufour michel
si roger bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
petit tour de table rapide
et extrêmement série lh je sais pas si
dans votre entourage un juge les gens
pensent que vous connaissez déjà le
résultat
final est de vous demander
alec
vraiment tout peut encore arriver le
pauvre est là
et les commentaires que j'obtiens le
plus souvent leur entourage c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe attendez pour la
plupart des gens se demandaient au
déclenchement de la course électorale ce
qui suivait ça depuis le début je disais
bon mais on a le choix ça va être un
gouvernement libéral minoritaire ou
libérale majoritaire pas mal ce qui
était dans l'air du temps depuis
maintenant plusieurs jours la
possibilité d'avoir conservateur est
bien réel donc déjà sept bambins qu'est
ce qui se passe ou ça bouge et comment
ça se fait qu'on en est là lebel il ya
plusieurs explications possibles mais le
résultat est le même c'est
qu'effectivement c'est presque plus
évidemment des sondages qui soit
dépendamment de la journée alors on
arrive là deux semaines pile jo pour
jour avant le vote avec une incertitude
de très très grande un peu comme c'était
le cas en 2019 à peu près à ce moment ci
la course en 2019 c'était extrêmement
serré aussi donc on va avoir une fin de
campagne assez dynamique je pense et on
le vit en 2019 un seul point de
pourcentage qui séparaient au profit des
conservateurs les libéraux et les
conservateurs christian dufour j'en ai
tout dans l'analyse cette campagne
ils réagissent deux semaines c'est ce
que je pensais pas qu'ils restent aussi
peu de choses que je réponds aussi c'est
que ça va être un gouvernement
minoritaire au fond il est quasiment
avoir à choisir entre un gouvernement
libéral est d'avis qu'un gouvernement
conservateur
et moi ça me fait passer beaucoup de
temps comme biais déjà moi moi je me
demande est ce la question de l'urma
fabius qui est ce on ne s'assoit pas s
avec qui on continue la pandémie est ce
qu'on continue avec justin trudeau et
des libéraux ou est-ce qu'on enchaîne
avec une auto des six la question lui ça
sera en défaveur de jeter de l'eau parce
qu'il incarne le des jeudis il incarne
la pandémie et je croque au delà de ce
qu'on n'aura pas de bien pensants dans
les médiums une attitude très profonde
au sein de la population qui veut
peut-être changer juste de personnes
masquées rideau tout ça est assez
premier ministre c'est ça c'est ça c'est
le dernier jour c'est bien beau de dire
qui est paul on peut pas le diaboliser
qui est sympathique mais là on se
demandait ce que vraiment la stature
d'un ministre ou pas
mais c'est intéressant michel surgi ce
que dit christian sait que la pandémie
qu'il devait aider le sort des libéraux
dans leur esprit dans l'esprit de
beaucoup de gens au début quelqu'un qui
se dit moi je veux tourner la page peut
en entendre parler il peut être tenté de
tourner la page on monsieur trudeau
on voit beaucoup de chiffres dans les
sondages les etc les gens veulent un
changement ça c'est une des données du
du casse tête
je retourne actuellement et mona pas de
beaucoup mais maintenant dans les
sondages c'est à lui de la gagne et
autres et il donne l'impression depuis
le début de la campagne qui joue faut
pas perdre mais là il faut qu'à il a
gagné cette élection là tu sais pas
dégénéré comme aujourd'hui qui vont
l'aider
c'est vraiment tellement juste que vous
venez de dire michel puis on va le voir
sur les armes on va écouter les extraits
il jouait pour ne pas perdre pour faire
perdre on a l'impression que quand ça se
corse foca et l attaque et on écoute
convient
je suis le chef et on va maintenir nos
restrictions en ce qui concerne les
armes à feu et avoir un processus pour
une revue de notre système de
classification de d'enlever la politique
et c'est très important pour moi d'avoir
une approche sérieuse ciblé sur la
sécurité problèmes et de respecter le
statut quo maintenant et avoir un
processus indépendant
lui a fait des promesses au lobby des
armes à feu pour se faire élire
de
renverser
ce qu'on a fait pour bannir les armes
d'assaut
et là il s'est fait prendre jeudi passé
et il doit renverser des décisions
qu'ils avaient prises et qui a donné
dans sa plate forme
il vient de changer sa plateforme
soi-disant et c'est perso du leadership
je commence avec vos tours de table sur
les armes
journée et je devrais dire quelques
jours difficiles pour monsieur toul
c'était un piège lui même fabriqué dans
lequel il s'est enfermé
quand ils ont fait le programme
conservateur ils n'ont pas pensé à l'air
du temps les armes à feu actuellement ce
problème quotidien depuis ce qui s'est
passé à ottawa cette semaine où vous
êtes à montréal c'est encore un problème
j'attendais cela terre qu'il ya même une
augmentation des crimes par arme à feu à
québec qui est quand même pas une des
plus grandes villes une vélo ou
d'habitude ce problème
alors dans l'air du temps il ya des gens
qui disent et savoir faire il ya des
questions de sécurité et le monsieur
otto larizza il faut respecter les
droits des tireurs sportifs et puis on
va avoir un comité qui va regarder la
liste de 15 sans armes prohibées savoir
lesquels on peut retourner dans en
circulation ou lesquels on va devoir
revenir c'est pas la réponse que les
gens attendent et
ça ouvre la porte à monsieur trudeau a
parlé de leadership
c'est ça qui va qui risque d'être le
problème de monsieur autour le cours des
prochains jours c'est qu'il faut qu'ils
montrent qu'ils étaient trop lié
ministre à date ok il faut
qu'il faut pas tirer écrivain plateforme
à tous les jours à christian non
déjà il faut qu'ils soient plus adroits
moi c'est ce que je réalise que je pense
au début que c'était parce qu'en france
ait été moins à l'aise manifestement
qu'en anglais mais même en anglais il
n'est pas capables de manoeuvrer en fait
dans ses doutes au sierra bon je ne nie
pas l'importance objectif du dossier du
contrôle des armes à feu mais c'est plus
compliqué que justin trudeau veux bien
que bien croire puis un aspect
pédagogique
karine tout ne devrait peut-être adopté
la domotique est pas capable moi c'est
ce qui me frappe c'est quand il est
confronté à des enjeux complexes dont il
n'est pas capable en fait d'y répondre
de façon crédible soit disant ne pas
dire qu'il serait pas un bon premier
ministre mais reste que ça paraît mal
pour quelqu'un qu'on regarde en cela ses
tubes procès prévu du canada un jeu moi
je me dis ben alors ils présentent
répondent de façon un peu plus habiles
pas droit
et précise ouais alec est ce que vous
pensez de ça c'est stratégique cos une
incapacité
je pense que on est en train de dépasser
le point où la proposition des
conservateurs une importance
on a des dix la plateforme à 22 semaines
et demi après l'avoir présenté les
candidats conservateurs sur le terrain
que non la position pour changer
toujours la même on va revenir en
arrière sur les vaisseaux et renault
tout mais je vais garder l'interdiction
mais seulement jusqu'à la révision une
fois la révision de la loi faire tu
pourrait permettre certaines âmes le
problème de renault tout s'éclaire en
doute quatrième ou cinquième jour c'est
un problème de sincérité les gens vont
commencer à se demander s'il est présent
n'importe quoi pour être élu s'il est
prêt à dire une chose en français pour
parce que c'est qu'au québec de contrôle
des armes c'est important parce qu'on a
eus corrige dans le sud on ne lui voit
les techniques pendant que les tueries
de la mosquée à québec ce que ces
candidats sur le terrain qui dicte
bresse à dire
en arrière et le moment donné car la
crédibilité du chef commencent à être
touchés et qu'on aspire à devenir
premier ministre on entre dans une
complication pas mal la campagne est
sage et christian la météo de la
sincérité
est-ce qu'il a la force c'est ce qui me
frappe sky a la stature et à la force
c'est ça dont le chinois est sûr que j
qu'une semaine
ces questions ça oui alesi michel ça ne
fait pas c'est pas trés c'est ce que à
la campagne de joe clark finalement été
mais minoritaire et qui peut rester très
longtemps c'est exactement ce même genre
de questions là que composaient le gars
des libéraux c'est un leader et au
leader et on voit un peu la même chose
chez monsieur autour de quelqu'un qui
est qui qui fondamentalement est des six
qui est pas capable de vivre avec une
position catholique
monsieur clark a duré combien de tam
chêne neuf mois
moi j'en connais claude
sujets dont anvers ne faut pas prédire
le résultat on pourrait les canadiens
pourraient nous surprendre s'apprête
majorité mais ça va être l'autre sujet
abordé si on veut pas d'élections au 18
mois
ce qui vaut une réflexion christian sur
soul l'acte collectif qui nous qui nous
entraîne vers des élections perpétuelle
moi je dirais que ma position mais si
maintenant on avait demandé à nos
critères ça pourrait faire la faire
deviner canadiens qui auraient pu ni
justin trudeau dans sa suffisance lui il
ya déclenché des élections sans raison
d'autres d'être majoritaire donc on l'a
on le reconduit minoritaire mais on n'a
pas été assez impressionné par autour
pour lui donner le pouvoir de façon
minoritaire c'est un peu
[Musique]
[Rires]
comme celle ci est ce pas nous qui c'est
pas nous qui décidons
je veux entendre
la question des manifestants anti
vaccins entre autres la sécurité je veux
entendre les chefs sur cette question de
la sécurité non pas sécurité pas qu'il
soit vraiment en danger mais la sécurité
des événements et du discours que le
discours soit les brawn et côte
c'est désolant de voir cesser cette
minorité frustré cette ces gens
marginalisés
cette petite fraction de notre
population qui croît pas dans la science
menacé de nous ramener en arrière et
c'est encore plus désolant de voir qu'un
auto doit leur laisser de la place
j'aimerais voir une campagne sur les
idées les harcèlements des candidats
n'importe quel parti sont sont
inacceptables j'aimerais voir les débats
sensibles sont les manifestations
semblent absolument
chaque partie chaque chef de partie
chaque candidat des parties s'expriment
les gens écoutent font un choix vote
donc n'importe quoi qui empêche en chef
de s'exprimer je le dénonce mais encore
plus si c'est agressif encore plus ces
violents y est on est on est reçu des
menaces on continue de reçu des menaces
et c'est un problème je n'ai pas d
inquiétude mais j'ai des inquiétudes
pour mon équipe j'ai des inquiétudes
pour les gens qui travaillent avec moi
avec nous j'ai des inquiétudes pour mes
bénévoles vous pouvez manifester vous
devez c'est votre droit mais nous ne
vous ne pouvez pas menacer les gens avec
des propos haineux violent raciste
misogyne est
parce que les manifestations qu'on a vu
un mélange la de colère disons il ya des
propos dans certains camps raciste ya
des affiches c'est un problème récurrent
de candidats racisées qui se font
dessinent et à toute heure de show il ya
un climat qu'on dénonçait ce qu'on
exagère le climat où il ya vraiment un
climat inquiétant alec
et clément inquiétant ça ressemble un
peu à ce qu'on voit aux états unis où
malheureusement les
chefs des grands partis démocratiques et
ne peut plus faire de bain de foule lors
des campagnes présidentielles parce que
c'est trop risqué la sécurité est
omniprésente donc le contexte partager
avec les gens aient diminué même chose
pour certains sénateurs certains
représentants des chambres du congrès je
trouve que ça ressemble beaucoup à ce
que nouveau américain en termes de
climat électoral dans ce qu'il ya de
plus laid au delà des chefs va dire que
je pense que justin trudeau autre
capable de vivre avec les manifestations
même assez hostile sur son parcours ce
que je trouve de marché que s'intimide
ceux qui se rassemblent pour aller
écouter un chef que ce soit juste un
être doux que ce soit quelqu'un d'autre
ou j'espère juste être eu d'eau mais les
gens attablés en terrasse les gens qui
s'en vont dans des pays candidats des
députés parfois avec leur famille avec
leurs enfants veulent entendre que le
chiffre à dire pour se faire une opinion
puis la belle vous avez une offre de
manifestants qui scandent des enjeux des
injures qui sont plus de bruit
questionnerait réunion et le celi ce
moment donné ça devient et
anti-démocratique select haïti mais les
gens qui le veulent à ces rassemblements
là on franchit un pas qu'on n'avait pas
franchi au canada les dernières
michel c
l'ancien greffier du conseil privé qui
avait témoigné pendant la faire seule
réponse j'oublie son nom là mais avait
dit moi je j'ai peur du climat je parle
que quelqu'un je fasse je suis pas dans
l'oeuf
il ya donc beaucoup de gens qui ont
réfléchi à ça qu'ils disent de toute
façon
l'atmosphère est pas belle et pas bonnes
au canada pour le débat politique qui
l'a pas dit on peut bien sûr exacerber
un certain nombre de choses
cela dit on pas que monsieur trudeau a
eu un peu trop loin dans l'extrait qu'on
a joué à hernych et faire de la place à
ces gens là dans son parti ça c'est
peut-être allé trop loin on peut pas on
peut quand même imputé ces
manifestations la même si on a plus
qu'un militant conservateur dans la
foule on peut point de [ __ ] et ses
manifestations là au parti conservateur
et le premier ministre vient avec le
terrain et il part à travers temps tire
des problèmes et évidemment il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont très très près
de la pandémie qui accepte pas les
mesures sanitaires qui accepte pour
toujours la séance alors
c'est sûr que ça laisse se manifesta
campagne électorale mais je ne croyais
pas que ça mais aussi aussi violent lui
aussi tueur
oui on a fait un petit christian je vous
donne la parole on a fait un petit vox
pop je suis allé sur l'avenue montréal
autrefois sur le passeport vaccinale qui
si on en parle souvent sale à l'émission
vous êtes content c'est très bien et en
actions peau mais les gens que j'ai
rencontrés étaient plutôt pour et je me
suis fait envoyer certains messages par
des gens là anti-vaccins c'est pas jojo
la la il ya ce climat là
est ce qu on exagère que six ans selon
vous
une américanisation malheureusement de
notre culture politique un différents
niveaux puis au niveau en fait de
l'agressivité [ __ ] si on ajoute les
réseaux sociaux si on ajoute la crise
inter ça commence à faire beaucoup
choisi pour ceux qui ont de la mémoire
l'eyrieux trudeau avait reçu des
bouteilles de bière lors de la
manifestation là en 1968 la femme de
monsieur gilles rognoni a été agressé
donc c'est pas la première fois quand
même que c'est sincère pauline marois
mais l'extrait que de monsieur w jouer
tantôt on a quand même troublé le jeu 3d
je trouve que je sais pas correct que le
premier ministre soit agressif à ce
point là à l'égard des opposants entre
autres à l'égard des gens qui sont pas
vaccinés muller autant il faut dire
qu'il faut se faire vacciner moi je le
dis je comprends pas les actions
professionnelles mais de jeu ne souffre
que trudeau il diabolise trop les gens
qui sont pas fait vacciner est le garant
fait comme des ennemis je trouve ça
correct après midi
pas plus que le crime ait auxi qu à la
base donc faudrait que les leaders
politiques se retient et cet extrait
l'eau trouvée troublant est inacceptable
c'est ce que je trouve le premier
ministre est pas là pour commencer à
dire yeux de la population qui sont des
sondés diable parce qu'ils veulent pas
vous êtes qu'il souligne trop à grands
traits la refus d'une portion la
population des antilles en fait des
ennemis et en fait des ennemis
en même temps et
sur les convaincre très bien
merci beaucoup varié de paratonnerre
michel c c'est moi qui va se transforme
en paratonnerre sa combine oui l'heure h
en vie'' sur le ciel d'ottawa je vous
salue messieurs à très bientôt au revoir
à l'égal de la peau pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit